ladies and gentlemen
dear participants the ocean race has now
been sailing the waves for almost
50 years the ocean is your arena
and every day you feel its unique
strength
and power but you also
sense and see its growing fragility
you've seen it change and suffer
and you are helping it to heal
you have been removing plastics from the
ocean
you have been tackling pollution with
your own hands
you have been raising awareness on ocean
rights
and campaigning for action on
overfishing
i very much welcome the fact that this
summer several teams will carry
scientific equipment on board
this will help measure microplastics in
the water
and collect data about the impact of
climate change on the seas
although the ocean can produce a mighty
roar
as its waves crash on our shores
it has no voice in our public debates
so i salute you for speaking up for it
at events like today's summit
like you the european commission wants
to see a notion
that is healthy and full of life
biodiversity loss is one of the greatest
threats
to our planet and to human health
our seas and oceans are a particular
concern
they are our most natural ally in the
fight against climate change
and they are the first to feel its
effects
and that is why last month the
commission set out a new approach for
sustainable
blue economy in the european union
because in addition to having a crucial
role in regulating our climate
the ocean's rich biodiversity
provides us with essential goods and
services
it is critical for energy production for
tourism
for transport or trade the blue economy
provides
4.5 million jobs in the european union
alone
but for sustainable future
all blue economy sectors will have to
reduce their environmental
and climate impact because
tackling the climate and biodiversity
crisis
requires healthy seeds and we have to
make sustainable use of their resources
and this is why we are also promoting
across the world
the eu's expertise environmental action
and innovative business solutions
to support this i can announce that we
will update our
international ocean agenda next year
the commission will lead efforts on a
global agreement on plastics
and it will embed a circular approach
across our economy ahead of this year's
crucial biodiversity crop 15 in china
and the climate cop 26 in the uk we will
also
focus our diplomatic energy on
protecting
our oceans for example
the eu and its member states are
proposing to establish
two new large-scale marine protected
areas in the southern ocean we will do
this together with a number of
like-minded partners
if approved they would protect an area
of over
3 million square kilometers
and as we head to kunming in october for
the biodiversity cup 15
we are working towards global
commitments
our aim is to protect 30 percent of our
land and sea
a commitment we have already made at
european level
and now we are also working to increase
global climate ambition
at cup 26 in glasgow europe has already
committed to reach climate neutrality by
2050
it is our historic duty to reduce
emissions
and pollution to bring us back into
balance with the limits of
our planet in glasgow
and in kunming we want to see even
more international partners joining us
ladies and gentlemen as you race with
purpose
across our ocean we too race with
purpose towards net zero let us sail
together
and let's hope for fair winds thank you